hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
this is the 2015 Moto X pure addition or
Moto X style depending on where you live
so this is it is the new Moto X of
course it looks very familiar to last
year because it shares the same body
style of the 2014 phone which you can
tell by the build materials the metal
rails the antenna bands and the
unmistakable curves so what is new first
of all it's a little bit bigger again
and it gets a new backplate design still
with a dimple which is pretty nice for
holding it but a bit more narrow and
also still totally customizable in moto
maker and there are also some new back
materials so I went with this rubberized
back on the base model and while you can
opt to go with like a wood or a leather
on the back if you do stick with this
rubber option you pretty much don't need
any cases or skins with this phone it is
one of the grippy ax stones out there
which makes it really easy to hold
despite being bigger there's also now a
combo nano SIM tray and micro SD card
slot up top for expandable storage and
you still get the same button placement
and the same ridged power button from
before up front are the biggest
improvements though one a quad HD IPS
display and two stereo speakers again so
last year for some reason the Moto X
switched back to speaker only on the top
and not at the bottom so this year we
get that stereo upgrade back and they're
right up there as the best sounding
speakers in any smartphone nice and loud
and front facing right next to HTC ones
boom sound alarm clocks are super loud
notification sounds and music get really
loud with very little distortion and
watching videos and gaming gives you
that stereo audio experience again as
things move across the display which is
really awesome you simply can't do that
without stereo speakers now the back
again on the Moto X is non removable so
you don't have access to the battery but
you do get turbo charging and again I'm
a really big fan of fast charging and
smart phones I've talked about them past
the phone itself already has a pretty
decent battery life as I'll talk about
in a second but the ability to just like
plug in for a few minutes at a massive
amount of charge is super useful even if
the phone does last pretty much all day
now inside you will find some pretty
high-end specs the Snapdragon 808 chip
the Adreno 418 GPU and three bytes of
RAM now one thing that's really easy to
forget about this Moto X pure is how
much it costs now some of it is because
of the similarities and build with last
year but this is now technically a sub
$400
our phone totally off-contract and
that's really impressive now that's sort
of blurring a line between these
flagships that are six seven hundred
dollars and the more budget phones like
the oneplus 2 or phones even lower price
but this still is technically the
highest end flagship that Motorola makes
so it's really impressive that they can
get all this in such an inexpensive body
this is the best smartphone you can get
for under 400 bucks now arguably the
biggest change for this new Moto X is
moving from last year's 1080p LED
display to this year's quad HD IPS LCD
display so this is an interesting choice
for a couple reasons on the panel itself
you know viewing angles are pretty good
and it's overall a pretty nice bright
crispy display my only technical
complaint would be it's not quite as
bright as others in high outdoor lights
so not quite readable and it doesn't get
quite as dim either in the lowest of low
light I really do miss the AMOLED
display of last year's Moto X though
they switch to IPS LCD and I'm coming
from you know a Samsung phone for
example with a super high-end quad HD
Super AMOLED display and of course this
by comparison with a much more expensive
phone doesn't look quite as good but
again it's a 400 ollar phone and it's
pretty great for what you're getting
that being said an IPS display versus
AMOLED you still have to light all of
the pixels when you're showing things
like your active display notifications
which means at night you'll see the
entire panel sort of light up a little
bit just to show that I haven't found it
has a major effect on battery but I
still would have liked to have seen an
AMOLED display in this new Moto X now
the other biggest change here with this
phone is the brand new 21 megapixel Sony
camera sensor the camera in the
smartphone is also as Motorola's claimed
much improved from the last version it's
definitely now way better than any other
Motorola smartphone camera in the past
which is great but despite being 21
megapixels it's not quite measuring up
to the super high-end flagship phones
that are six seven eight hundred dollars
this is a prime example of in a camera
more megapixels doesn't necessarily mean
better outdoors the photos can look
really nice from the Moto X of course
with great sharpness and detail and
decent color and dynamic range I like
that it's not too aggressive with the
sharpening like you might find from a
Samsung camera but you still get plenty
of detail there is no optical image
stabilization though so once you get
into
out so great light or not ideal
conditions the photos break down pretty
quickly and you also become more aware
of the limited dynamic range bottom line
is this isn't the first phone I would
choose if I was looking to take a lot of
great photos or videos but it's enough
of an improvement that it's good enough
for most people my biggest complaint
about the camera now is actually the
software I'm really not a big fan of the
Motorola camera app they try to keep it
super simple with the menus sort of
tucked away on the left and one giant
shutter button with the whole viewfinder
and I guess I'm okay with it now because
I've learned it but I still don't like
tapping the whole viewfinder to take a
photo and having to drag around the
focus indicator to focus
I think tap to focus is much more
intuitive and a shutter button would be
really welcome
anyway outside of those things the
camera and the speakers and the display
and the new specs the rest of this phone
is very similar to last year's Moto X
which is actually a really good thing
the software experience is largely the
same as last year which is to say near
stock android 5.1 with a few Motorola
additions in useful places you get that
Moto app which is housing most of the
Moto magic and a lot of its functions
continue to get updated through the Play
Store so it gets better over time and
you can use moto actions to double chop
to turn on the flashlight that one's new
you can also double twist to open the
camera quickly which means I don't need
a camera shortcut on my homescreen
anywhere and you still have infrared
sensors to let you wave over the phone
to see your notification preview in moto
display and there's more stuff like this
all over the place that can be added as
it gets to learn your behavior and I
kept noticing overall performance as an
ear stock Android phone throughout this
guy is really good it's one of these
smoothest quad HD phones I've used I'd
say just as smooth as something like
galaxy s6 or note 5 through every day
performance and multitasking despite
having a gig less of RAM and a different
ship battery life was also very solid it
typically made it to the end of the day
for me which is a nice change from some
other phones I've been testing recently
but yeah it approach four hours of
screen on time by the end of the day no
problem and if I had a heavy day with
like a lot of navigation or a lot of
gaming or something
I'm usually near a power source so quick
charging pretty consistently save the
day so at the end of the day like I've
said the Moto X pier is definitely going
to give you the best multimedia
experience on any smartphone under 400
bucks and it's also likely one of the
best
overall experiences in this budget it's
near stock Android so it's probably
going to get updates very quickly and
I'd expect marshmallow on this guy
pretty soon of course being just south
of 400 bucks it's often going to be
compared to the oneplus 2 also just
south to 400 bucks I would give the
multimedia experience edge like I said
to the Moto X peer better higher
resolution display front-facing speakers
and a slightly better camera despite not
having optical image stabilization but
if you're more into the software
customization experience this is going
to be your edge here plus it has in my
opinion a little bit better build
quality and you get things like a
fingerprint reader and the alert slider
on the side little bonuses like the
interchangeable back then again moto
maker over here you can make this point
look exactly the way you want it to
either way I'll leave the link to the
oneplus 2 review down below if you want
to check that out and that's been it for
the Moto X pure thank you for watching
this review video guys and I'll talk to
you guys in the next one peace